-It is time for
the mimic challenge!
-♪ Mimic challenge ♪
♪ Mimic, mimic challenge, yeah ♪
-And here to help me out is
the one and only Maya Rudolph,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's how it works.
We each have a bunch of items
to make noise with,
and we're going to take turns
making a sound with an object.
Then the other person has to
immediately match that sound
as precisely as they can.
Are you ready for this?
-Absolutely.
-Okay, good.
Maya, I will be the first --
I will make the first noise.
Okay. Maya?
-Okay.
-Make -- Make this sound.
[ Key clacking ]
[ Blowing sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty good.
I like that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
You ready?
-Alright, my turn.
Yeah, whenever you're ready.
-Ready, Jimmy?
-Are you supposed to, like,
not see what I'm doing?
-I'm not gonna look, but --
I don't know.
-This is really complicated.
-Okay.
-Alright, ready?
Jimmy, make this sound.
[ Tissue whooshes ]
-Can you do it again?
[ Exhales sharply ]
-Yeah, that was it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Maya?
-Yes, sir.
-Make this sound.
-Okay.
[ Milk gurgling ]
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
[ Sputtering ]
Wait, wait.
-What?
What?
-Wait.
-This sound.
[ Milk gurgling ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughing ]
-Okay.
[ Chortling softly ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
Okay, that was good.
-Oh, good news, Jimmy,
I got another one.
-Gotcha. Alright,
now I can see it.
-Alright, Jim.
[ Laughing ] What? Jimmy.
-Jim. You can call me Jim.
-Jim. It's Jim. It's Jim today.
-It's Jim today. I got it.
-Alright, James,
make this sound.
[ Tape screeches ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Whooshes ]
Maya.
-That was accurate.
♪♪
-Mm-hmm?
-Maya, make this sound.
[ Clicking, water squirting ]
-[ Exhaling sharply ]
[ Water squirting ]
[ Exhaling sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
You had the face.
"Psst."
-It was -- It had an attitude.
-It did have an attitude.
-"Pfft."
-Okay, ready?
-Yes.
-Alright, Jimmy.
-Here we go.
-Make this sound.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Clattering ]
-[ Laughs ] That's very good.
That was...perfect.
-Maya...
-Perfect. Yes, sir.
-...make this sound.
-Okay.
[ Toy squeaking nasally ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Squeaking nasally ]
[ High-pitched ] "Uh,
sounds like me on prom night."
[ Laughter ]
[ Squeaking ]
-[ Groans ]
[ Squeaking nasally ]
[ Clucking ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Both chuckling ]
Holy -- Okay.
-Wow.
-It's -- This is normal.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, Jimmy make this --
This looks ridiculous.
Okay, Jimmy, make this sound.
[ Bass guitar strums ]
[ Low vocalizing ]
[ Laughter ]
It was like The Breeders.
♪ A-ooh ♪
-♪ A-ooh-ah ♪
-Was that Breeders?
-Yeah.
-Maya Rudolph, make this sound.
[ Drill whirring ]
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Humming, whirring ]
[ Drill whirring ]
♪♪
-Okay.
My turn.
-Oh, it's your turn, alright.
-I see it. Oh.
-Okay, Jimmy, make this sound.
-Gosh.
[ Squeaking, squelching ]
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
that's not how you sit on a --
Like, wow.
-Here, maybe it's better
if I sit on it, right?
-Probably.
-Stand by.
I'm a professional.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, Jimmy, make this sound.
-Yep.
[ Cushion squelches ]
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
[ Blowing, sputtering ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Air squelching ]
-That's it. That's it.
-Was it right?
[ Muttering indistinctly ]
-Ooh, I really --
I went through these fast.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright. Here we go.
Maya...
-Mm-hmm.
-...make this sound.
[ Goat screams ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Goat screaming ]
-[ Strained scream ]
[ Goat screams ]
[ Both shrieking ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Aah!
My thanks to Maya Rudolph!
Watch Maya host
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with musical guest Jack Harlow.